you're actually tougher than you think
build that mental emotional toughness
one success model the best
what's up belief nation it seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most common rules that successful
people follow be tough also if you want
to know a Jordan Peterson grant cardone
Jaco wellick and others have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in description below if
you're gonna speak effectively you have
to know way more than you're talking
about you have to go build
self-confidence people want to know how
to stop the laziness and they want to
know how to stop the procrastination
[Music]
you're actually tougher than you think
you never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because you know people play a role in
their own demise so to speak when you
had opportunity to go out and explore or
withdraw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid so it's not only that you were
over protected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the fact
that you were over protected and run
back there whenever you had the
opportunity you know so maybe you're a
kid in the playground right and you're
having some trouble with other kids and
you know in the back of your mind
I should deal this with deal with this
myself but you go and tell your mom and
get her to intervene and you know that
that's not right you know that you're
breaking the social contract but it's
easier and so that's what you do you run
off to an authority figure and hide
behind the Great Father right roughly
speaking well the problem with that is
you don't learn how to do it yourself so
then you have to relearn it painfully
when you're 40 so then you take people
out you say well what are you afraid of
rank it from 1 to 10 so 10 is what make
a list of 10 things you're afraid of the
least the thing you're least afraid of
will call number 10 so we'll start with
that
okay well I'm afraid of elevators ok
well let's let's look at a picture of an
elevator let's have you imagine being in
an elevator let's go out to an elevator
and let you watch the terrible jaws of
death open because that's how you're
responding to it symbolically right and
you're gonna do that at it at the the
closest proximity you can manage you
find out you go do that
it works you're nervous as hell
especially an from an anticipatory
perspective shaking you go out you stop
you watch it happen and you actually
calm down you do that 10 times it no
longer bothers you well what you've
learned that you didn't die but more
importantly than that you've learned
that you could withstand the threat of
death that's what you've learned and
then you move a little closer and then
you move a little closer and then you
move a little closer and finally you're
back in what's no longer the elevator
from a symbolic perspective it's a tomb
right it's it's it's a place of
enclosure and isolation and you learn
hmm
turns out I can withstand that
and then you're met much more together
much more confident and that's often one
of the things that often happens in
situations like that I've seen this
multiple times is that if you run
someone through an exposure training
process like that and toughen them up
they'll often start standing up to
people around them in a way they never
did before mr. Carnegie was a hard
bastard Vanderbilt was a hard bastard
Henry Ford the first was a hard bastard
Rockefeller was a hard bastard Steve
Jobs was a ruthless hard bastard
as Apple's CEO Cooke regularly begins
sending emails at 4:30 in the morning on
Sunday he's a hard bastard why are all
these guys they changed the world got
one thing in common take the prisoners
and then we got you a stiff drink and a
good kill most people in this room I'm
ashamed to say and forgive the stiff
drink just a good my proceeds from
PayPal acquisition were 80 180 million
ba-ba-ba-ba then I had a borrow money
for rent these guys myself included are
all in if they believe in what they're
doing they put all their money at risk
on which I have several times not in
recent years SpaceX worker reveals a
brutal company motto motto helped him
survive all nighters working for Elon
Musk notorious workaholic Elon Musk is
so tied to his office that he's been
known to sleep on the floor I slept on
the floor
Ford slept on the poor job slept on the
floor day slept on the floor success
leaves Clues you weenies
I still work 50 60 hours a week and I
haven't had it work in 35 years I think
that there's a shortage of real men on
this planet I think most men are I mean
frankly just [ __ ] you know I don't
know if your audience can handle that
word but I could look man if you can't
get your money right something's wrong
if you can't take care of your family
you got to ask yourself how much of a
man are you like for me that identifies
me as a man my ability to take care of
my family I don't just mean financially
but I do mean financially right my job
as a as a head of household is to take
care of the economics of the household
you know the word economy if you look it
up in the dictionary it comes from
managing the household it had nothing to
do with the business it was about
managing the household so if you go back
a thousand years we've been managing
households my job as a man is to provide
a place where it's warm place where we
can sleep a place where we're protected
place where there's food right not money
right I need to be able to take care of
the family shelter food clothing and I
need to have some fun my family wants to
have fun we want to have experiences so
I need to provide a secure environment
for them so they're not think bad things
aren't just happening and so so men need
to like bone up man
like the government can't take care of
you bone up you know this yeah bone up
get strong right strong case so get a
get a backbone and take care of your
family and quit blaming the government
or making excuses that your neighbor or
the economy or what whatever conditions
the guy I've had some terrible
conditions in my life from the age of 15
till 25 it was awful for me ten years
nobody would want to go through the ten
years that I went through did do some
people have it worse than I did probably
but I don't want to do those ten those
ten years were terrible for me is
degrading as a human being can
experience drugs yeah drugs but mostly
just so many bad choices so many bad
people you know so so much it's self
self deprivation and
and just a lack of self esteem and self
love for myself because of a lot of bad
choices so I understand what goes on
through for a person when they're making
bad choices and and and people just need
to man up
you know bone up the women need to do
the same thing by the way yeah women
they're stronger than men look I hate
pain any kind of pain women can handle
ten times the pain I can handle and I
know I've said before that knowledge is
the most important thing but the reality
is if you don't have the strength or
actually the health to back that up or
even to function as a human being
physically then your knowledge and your
mental strength doesn't really even
matter so that comes into play and being
big and strong is also totally useless
if you're mentally weak and you quit now
being mentally strong should actually
lead you to being physically strong
because if you are mentally strong then
you can work and train to become
physically strong but if you're mentally
weak then you will not hold the line on
the good food and the good workouts and
you won't get physically strong or
healthy so
can you be weak and strong at the same
time yes but I say be strong train your
physical strength and exercise your
mental strength by doing the right
things the hard things the things you
know you're supposed to do do them and
be as strong as you can mentally
physically and emotionally for yourself
for your team for your family hold the
line and be strong this is great line
that Will Smith said when somebody asked
what he's afraid of
and he said fear he's afraid of fear the
fear of here he doesn't like fear
whenever he recognizes that he's afraid
of something he wants to attack it to
get rid of it to combat it to always be
pushing through whatever his fears are
because his fear is prevented from doing
great things we wants to just run
straight into fear which is such an
interesting approach I don't think many
people have that mindset and just the
act of crushing of fear or combating the
fear makes you stronger makes you grow
makes you more comfortable and doing
other crazy things it expands your
circle of confidence and competence
the tricky part though is to catch
yourself the tricky part is to actually
acknowledge to yourself that you are
afraid of something because what we'll
often do is just come up with a rational
reason why we should do it instead of
admitting to ourselves that we're afraid
we'll come up with a justification I'm
not gonna start my business because you
know now it's not the right time because
you know this president's office because
whatever you come up with a bunch of
reasons and listen those reasons may be
true right a lot of those reasons have
some kind of practical value that's why
you pick them right you're not gonna
pick something totally crazy it's not
gonna be you know Martians might invade
planet Earth so I'm not gonna start my
business somebody told you that if you
told yourself that you wouldn't believe
it you came to live with it so all these
practical reasons that you come up with
they hold a shred of proof and so that's
what makes it feel like that's the real
and but really just afraid you're just
afraid to do something those aren't the
reasons they're there but they're not
the real reasons you're just afraid and
so catching yourself to understand that
this is the reason why I'm not doing
something important it's super critical
I think I said when you do catch
yourself then what do you do then you
start to try to take some kind of action
for so the example that I told before I
like to tell is when I was walking in
the street and I had my headphones on
and some quiet Street and I'm I'm
grooving and I'm shaking them dancing
now I'm doing a whole bunch of stuff and
then I get close to a busy intersection
and as soon as I see people around me i
tone down I start playing small start
playing it say
worried about their judge without me
worried about how they might be thinking
about me subconscious like I didn't even
didn't even tick didn't even register
that I was playing small right and this
is what we do normally right like
because we're afraid of failing the fear
of judgment we just play small by
default we just resort them back to it
and then I caught it I caught it they
realized what just happened
I was grooving and now I stopped because
there's a bunch of people on the street
that's not acceptable and then I made a
conscious effort to dance even bigger on
a busy street corner I'm I'm shaking it
up now I'm not going in somebody's face
and trying to prove a point I'm not
trying to get in somebody's space and
offend them but maybe what I'm doing
inspires them maybe what I'm doing gives
them a little bit of a smile yeah maybe
they think I'm crazy that's okay I don't
want to be afraid of that and so
whenever I can catch myself playing
small because of a fear then I try to
attack it the most difficult part is
still catching it and you may catch one
in a hundred I bet you I've already
played small a hundred times today they
didn't catch any just subconsciously
it's that's how we're wired you play
small daily hundreds of times you don't
even notice it when you do notice it
though when you do catch it you catch
your fear
get into the habit of pushing through it
get into the habit of running towards it
because the more you do that the more
you'll catch the next one
and you'll catch the next one and you
catch the next one and you've trained
yourself that when you're afraid of
something you're gonna attack it what is
a crazy audition that you had early on
you know we are here at the Screen
Actors Guild Awards getting that sag
card is a really big deal in the
beginning do you remember kind of a an
audition that made you freak out a
little bit I think I mean I relate to
pretty much every audition in the movie
I've had a version of those many many
times I think the hardest part was for
awhile I auditioned for a lot of things
which is great when you're an actor and
you're getting a lot of auditions and I
wasn't getting called back for anything
when I first moved to LA and and so they
just stopped sending me out so there was
a large swath of time where nobody
wanted me to even come in and I think
that feeling was actually worse than any
of the you know the initial auditions
and being kind of rejected I think
sometimes we want an easy life so I
think sometimes we want everybody to
love us and buy from us and so easy it's
so great it's all the sudden and with
all of my monitoring treatment she
didn't tell me I was special my dad
didn't do this to me my ex cheated on me
my ex did this and this person did this
and my friend did this on my boss oh my
gosh this is why I'm losing [ __ ]
those are all the reasons why you have a
shot at doing something big with your
life those are all the reasons those are
all the reasons why you can use as an
ammunition to say boom world I'm coming
I'm gonna do something big with my life
and no one expects it so rather than
looking at some of these tough times
that you may be going through today and
there you will be going through in the
future because depending on whatever age
you are you go from going to birthdays
to going to weddings to go on a birthday
kids being born to go into kids birthday
parties then you go to funerals no
matter what we're all going to funerals
eventually if you haven't already
started going to funerals that's called
life and the sooner you anticipate tough
times and the sooner you overcome every
single one of these tough times that you
think you're the only one that's going
through it when are you gonna look up
and people gonna look at you as an
example of somebody who is tough enough
to go through the difficult times and
now
a leader winning big and they one day
want to be just like you in 2010 you
know I kind of called myself I'm a
meathead I just lift weights and put him
down right I had kind of painted myself
into that corner why not go run a
marathon so I trained for six weeks and
went and ran a marathon it was the most
painful thing I ever did but I realized
that was more the suffering and the pain
and the more pain I had the more put me
into the zone of wanting to dominate so
it is a superpower
so I almost now go back and put myself
into these challenges Rob claiming I was
afraid of heights took on a six-week
challenge started climbing Ross wanted
to fight a professional MMA fighter so I
hired him trained for six weeks one of
the ring I got my ass kicked and choked
out but each time I did that it gave me
the sense of I can get over any obstacle
and if I can get over getting choked out
and punched and the pain of 26.2 miles
and a marathon or overcoming my fear of
heights surely I can build a business
surely I can take some criticism online
right but not enough people are willing
to build that mental emotional toughness
and the moment they do though persevere
Bistro
and very courageous be strong and very
courageous be strong and be of good
courage be strong and pull Sicily
because God knows that for what you're
going to do it is not by outer strength
[Applause]
you understand you understand see
company preach the straightness more -
girl its inner strength so my fourth one
is you got to have inner strength for
this fight it's not your outer strength
it's not by might nor by power but by my
spirit saith the Lord
so you gotta have that inner that inner
that inner that cut strips and delis
strength then temple define come hell a
Hal Wallis trip that rolled me out in
front of them an hour preach from a
chair strip that's an asset II to take a
lickin and keep on tickin that inner
strength that well I can't do as I would
I'm gonna do as I can
but I'm not will stop going to the best
ability
strong strong 30 years how has the crowd
changed like now it seems like
everyone's offended by every
it's like how does a very good point
people are sensitive now all the sudden
or oversensitive maybe there's a mag
graining quote migrating that created
the Simpsons there's this famous quote
where he says the world is filled with
people who are dying to be offended by
something what the world has now is an
Internet for those people to voice their
offense so they can make something out
of nothing they can spend your work and
make something that's beautiful look
like it's ugly advice verses like I say
my specialist is the age of spin so so
everyone is becoming a spin doctor so
it's now granted comedians make mistakes
it's part of the job you know and some
mistakes are easily forgivable some are
wildly more extreme but I did is that we
want a society where we are late allowed
to make mistakes were able to voice our
opinions and change our things so I just
I just let it rip I'm not afraid of the
audience you know I think the vast
majority of people that come out they
get it they know what it is and there's
always some people with insidious intent
they try to derail you
I would just spin the ball but it's you
know as you get as you go all the
business you guys it's toughen up and
and just hope that your numbers don't
come up I'm sure my next special have
somebody bad
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Kevin Durant on how to be tough
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one where do
you need to be tougher number two what
immediate action can you take on it
right now and number three how will you
stay consistent on being tougher
[Music]
so like I'll be getting bullied over
here I took the easy way out I don't
deserve any day that's it too easy
without easy this is no cuz it ain't
never had no easy
[Music]
there is no doubt in my mind it was a
crushing day for him when he knew that
the decision he had to make would be to
go to Golden State because he would
never want anybody there to think that
he didn't appreciate him that he didn't
mean every word he had ever spoken when
he was there kevin gave nine years to
OKC it's a long time and he gave
everything he had the tough decision was
made and you grow from it you learn from
it it's how you handle it we had a lot
of great moments together it's hard to
make you at the top of your profession
no matter what it is but it's easy for
people to describe it
this like banging works whole life to
get to this point and sometimes I don't
even enjoy it because you were the other
people got to sit and that's struggling
some days especially when you play an
NBA when all you hear is the noise it's
hard to tune it out as much as people
want us to like be tough mine have thick
skin sometimes it's our tonight not take
up for yourself and be like yo work hard
as hell but you know we're not in the
gym after shooting around you have to
practice it you know it's going off to
my head like day before game I don't
know it's just a game that some people
would be real life to this
I think people get this idea that like
he made his decision and then on July
4th he was like bring out the ace of
spades let's pop champagne I'm going to
go on stay I mean it was the opposite
like his July 4th barbecue didn't exist
like there was no celebration he was in
more pain making that decision than
anybody because that was the opposite of
what he had done his whole life which
was make sure that everybody was happy
if you want to know how to deal with
difficulties and problems in your life
check out the video right next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
great people don't go through they grow
to the difficulties that come on their
path problems will come